[Musique]
rendez vous était donné à la gare de
cernay pour la signature d'un acte de
vente entre la ville et le département
en jeu ce bâtiment l'ancienne gare
désaffectée
si aujourd'hui le trafic des trains
reste élevée est vital aux
communications avec mme louise le
bâtiment qui accueillait autrefois les
bureaux est fermé depuis des années et
les payas jeunes plus axé compris
étaient municipal ce bâtiment historique
va connaître une seconde vie
la ligne de chemin de fer entre eux
mulhouse et henry dit ethan a été la
première réalisée dans l'est de la
france à l'époque du fait de
l'implantation des usines sur thann et
c'est vrai que cette gare bea a suivi
les vicissitudes de notre région
je le rappelle a changé cinq fois
nationalité alors qu'on n'avait rien
demandé
et aujourd'hui c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi que de pouvoir céder cette gare
au conseil départemental du haut rhin et
dans cette gare en accord avec le
conseil départemental vont être
regroupés tous les services à la
population
d'ici 2021 les services départementaux
de la solidarité seront installées dans
le bâtiment qui sera rénové objectif
améliorer la qualité du service et son
accessibilité au public
il s'est avéré depuis quelques années
que les 2 cms centres médico-sociaux de
cernay n'était pas n'exerçait plus dans
des conditions optimum et que pour plus
d'efficacité et plus de sécurité il
était logique de les re de les
rassembler fallait trouver un point de
chute
la municipalité de cernay ayant compris
cela nous a proposé l'ancienne gare de
cernay qui était propriété de la ville
quelques semaines nous serons prêts à
déménager s'il a vécu des locaux goût de
l'opération 650000 euros
une bonne affaire pour le département
pour faire des économies dans le cas
présent mieux valait investir
il aurait fallu de toute manière
retrouvez un point de chute
quel qu'il soit il aurait fallu faire
des travaux d'adaptation des locaux donc
un investissement certain s'imposait
nous étions aussi en location dans les
cms actuelle donc on fera une économie
de loyers ce qui nous permettra de
financée et d'amortir l'investissement
nécessaire pour l'ancienne gare en plus
vous l'avez vu la situation elle est
idéale vous la transmission du côté de
la commune si l'on se réjouit de
l'opération immobilière on est surtout
ravi de sa finalité en matière de
solidarité communes des départements
travaillent ensemble un même objectif
dans une période où les différentes
questions sociales sont si pressante
il était important autour de maintenir
ses services publics au plus près des
habitants
mais je pense que c'est un besoin non
seulement pour la ville de cernay par
l'ensemble du territoire
le volet social du département du
conseil départemental est important par
rapport à l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées par rapport aux ehpad par rapport
à la petite enfance par rapport à la mer
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est des
services extrêmement important est le
fait de les regrouper sur un endroit
facilite pour nos concitoyens
cette démarche pour qu'ils puissent
bénéficier facilement des services du
département en matière dette sociale
la proximité est déterminante
aujourd'hui pour les usagers pour te
l'ensemble des concitoyens de notre
territoire
c'est vraiment là la politique du
département du haut-rhin rentré dans les
territoires offrir un service de
proximité
le bâtiment accueillera l'ensemble des
publics concernés par le département des
jeunes enfants aux personnes âgées
dépendantes
grâce à ce bâtiment propriété maintenant
du département nous allons faire des
travaux et pouvoir rassembler en 2021
l'ensemble des services de la solidarité
tous les services liés à la personne le
social en a priori un puisque voilà tout
les êtres et des assistances sociales
seront seront là présente my à la petite
enfance la pmi la protection maternelle
et infantile
le pôle gérontologique tous les services
qui se rapporte aux plus fragilisés et
aux personnes les plus vulnérables les
personnes âgées
enfin tous les services sociaux qui sont
de la compétence du département
c'est vraiment le service au public par
excellence c'est notre coeur de métier
le choix du site c'est fait pour son
accessibilité
idéalement placé la gare sera accessible
à l'ensemble des habitants du bassin de
vie on est en coeur de ville
on est à côté des quartiers on est avec
un parking important on a le tram et on
a le ter donc c'est un endroit
stratégique pour regrouper tous les
services pour éviter que nos concitoyens
haye de droite et de gauche
c'est une belle opération au service des
populations
c'est c'est donc un grand atout un
service de proximité pour les habitants
de cerner les habitants du secteur
parce que nous avons coutume de dire que
le département
l acteur de proximité aux côtés des élus
locaux aux côtés de la population et
bien sonné la preuve les travaux de
rénovation devraient commencer
rapidement
ouverture au public prévue pour 2021
[Applaudissements]